creating a new culture in a company
has much more to do with sociology
than tools statistics or cloud services
however we typically rely on technical
transformations to create
a data-driven culture in this short talk
i will share with you
the main social issues i have found as a
head of data
in a multinational company to bring you
let's say
a social perspective on the data-driven
culture fostering
[Music]
first let's define what a real
data-driven culture is
data-driven companies street data as a
strategic
asset data is clean
centralized joinable accessible
so that anyone at the company can
leverage data through
self-service tools
and of course the goal is using data to
make
better decisions okay let's move to
data teams which are the main social
issues found in data teams
well quality is the primary concern
of data teams data teams satisfaction
comes from helping the company through
data
but when quality is so low
then they feel ashamed unable
frustrated set a high standard
for data quality invest in data
engineering
and have in mind that turnover
in data teams is closely related
to low quality data
data scientists hate reporting because
it's monotonous and never challenging we
all know that
the same could happen with simple
visualizations
remove this task from them
and create a separated theme
for these minor responsibilities
we spectate the scientists to be good
communicators
don't we but we don't prepare
the company to listen to them
and that is a significant source of
frustration
what's the use of hiring data scientists
if we are
not going to follow their suggestions
and recommendations communications
between
data teams and the rest of the company
are crucial for a healthy
data-driven culture focus on
good communications focus on
good interactions analyze
the motivations behind the bad ones
nobody likes working on the high
pressure
but in the case of data teams that can
lead you to all full results
the best advice here is give them
freedom
and trust them that's all um
decision makers decision makers are
responsible
for leading the company with their
decisions
so they play a very important role in
the company
and think of them for a moment
excellent salaries great experience
very capable broadly
respected
however they feel threatened by all this
data-driven movement if
we made decisions solely using data
then human decision makers
would be useless
the best recommendation here is to make
sure you understand and connect
with them emotionally be empathetic to
them
accept that they won't be able to
understand
statistics or even a simple graphic
help them grow
and be the best companion show them the
benefits
for their productivity if they use data
in decisions
and how that
can boost the cognitive productivity
let's be honest with ourselves data
statistics and algorithms don't have all
the answers
data can be messy incomplete
or biased and data scientists
are humans with limited knowledge
about statistics brahmin
and data and
intuition is 42 of course
always there to deceive us
decision makers won't feel attracted
by a world where data drives everything
at the contrary they will fight against
this world
so let's embrace the best of data
and intuition join them
to obtain the best of both worlds
and what about all the company in
general
well the foremost reason for the
opposition
to data-driven culture relies on
cognitive biases
those biases generate distrust
around the company and affect everyone
use facts from data analysis results to
fight
cognitive biases and reduce
skepticism
believers they can be in every corner of
your company
the best what you can do is ignoring
them use your energy and time with the
rest of the company
self-service data science has
i would say a dark side when you opened
your data and
offered tools to analyze it
then some workers might start to believe
that data science is very simple
then your mission will be to convince
them
that data science is much more than that
and what about new habits that we have
to introduce in
in the company how can we make sure that
new practices new habits are adopted and
maintained
new habits should be fundamentally
practical
and very clear prepared samples
offer trainings supervise
their adoption and persist
because new habits take time
data should lead the
cultural revolution measure the adoption
of new habits through data for instance
run surveys among your colleagues to
collect data
and then analyze this data and show
how to use this data to make
decisions
we can't impose a culture we must
convince
persuade and be influential
that's very hard you know the key
indicator to measure
our progress is the rate of convinced
colleagues
decide how you will measure it
it's up to you but make sure
you have a clear view of the percentage
of people in the company that
you still need to convince
it's been a pleasure to contribute to pi
data global 2020.
thank you very much